I risa got asked a question in my
mastermind group for one of my members
who asked me what is the switch that
changed the game for me so she recently
started the business she feels like
she's doing everything right she's off
trying to meet people time a network
she's making partnership deals she is
posted on social media she's making
videos who feels like she's doing
everything that she is doing right and
she wants to know it's just a matter of
keep on doing what she's doing or what
happened in my business that helped me
make the switch and so I want to share
three different instances that have
helped my businesses grow and hit new
levels the first was in my first
business was a software company and the
thing that saved me the switch that I
turned on was modeling success and I
told the story number times on my
channel but you know i was making three
hundred dollars a month barely able to
survive i told my business partner i
quit i felt totally worthless and
valueless and felt like I wasn't
contributing anything to this world I
wasn't having any success and the thing
that changed it was realizing I'm not
the first guy to try to sell software
before maybe there was nobody in my
industry was biotech software it was new
as I'm emerging there wasn't a big huge
player in that field yet so I didn't
model them but I looked at hey there's
been other people who built software
companies before how did they do it and
the one that really saved me was
Microsoft and Bill Gates and looking at
how Bill Gates got started how did he
build his first million dollars that's
what I wanted to do how do you go from
that idea to build in his first million
dollars and that literally saved my
business he did it through partnerships
and I then set out on the path to form
my own partnerships and within a month
or so i made my first deal that was
thirteen and a half thousand dollars and
at the time that was huge for me going
from three hundred dollars a month
eating beans for lunch every day
celebrating with McDonald's french fries
and we got a win to be making 13 and a
half thousand dollars in one deal that
may not seem like a lot of money to you
guys but that was a huge turning point
for me in my business
and I came from all in the success of
Bill Gates so I would look at two things
one poor people in your industry who've
gone on and done great things that you
could model and then also to who to
people that who do you look up to that
outside your industry who's a famous
entrepreneur that you really love you
respect you admire and research they're
starting days not necessarily what they
do right now you can still learn from
that but how did they get started and
what can you learn from that success to
apply it to your business so that that
mall in success it became the name of
this channel right mall in the Masters
I've tried to carry that through and
everything that I do and it's just the
idea that you don't have to come up with
every single idea yourself that whatever
problem you're facing it has already
been solved and by you recognizing that
and researching people that you can look
up to that can save you a lot of
headache a lot of hassle a lot of money
and get you back on track the second
thing that that turned the switch for me
in my next business was understanding
that I can't do it alone understand that
I need to build a team and the first
person I hired was a guy to do one hour
a day of database work and that saved me
more than one hour a day because he was
better at it than I was and allowed me
to focus on what I was really good at
and one of the best in the world that
and I think too many entrepreneurs spend
time on the things that they're not
really good at the things that they
don't really enjoy the things that they
don't really have an ambition or desire
to get better at they do it because they
feel they have to do it and then you
spend ten to twenty percent of your time
actually doing the things that you are
amazing that I need to flip that you
need to be spending eighty percent at
the time doing things that you are one
of the best in the world act and if you
can do that then you start to see
massive growth in your business and I
did it for me so is understanding that i
don't have to do it alone in that i
don't have to hire full-time person i
think that's a limiting belief for a lot
of people that was for me when i was
starting up I felt like well I don't
have the money to hire somebody to come
and do this for me and realizing that I
can hire send me for just an hour a day
or
can have some income for in a couple
hours a week does not cost you a lot of
money and can help get you on path to
where you need to go I'd also be looking
at tools and automation software to help
you do that as well but but that was a
switch when I understood that I I don't
need to do this all alone just like the
mall and success you don't have to have
all the ideas yourself when you bring on
a team you don't have to do all the work
yourself and I think that again allows
you to be the best version of yourself
and then the third switch that I had in
my business was what I incorporated my
one word when it was when I went all in
on believe I remember in my newsletter
that was my first test I thought believe
was too crazy was too big an idea and
that was going to be my first test and I
put out the newsletter and my sister was
the first one to write back and said i
love this message I actually read your
newsletter for the first time in a while
like Thank You Stephanie appreciate the
support there but it got it got an
insane engagement ring compared to my
other newsletters I made a video that
was a belief themed video and it did as
well as my next my most popular video
took a year to get to a hundred thousand
views this one got there in a month or
two months it was just insane and so
ever since then I've kind of gone all-in
and I've seen serious growth when you
look at my youtube channel I've had this
channel for six years I want to say and
it's really taken off in the past year
um where you know we're at a hundred
thousand subscribers a couple months ago
we're going to end at 150,000 plus this
month adding 15 to 20,000 new
subscribers every month and I've seen
both a newsletter I've seen growth in a
website and so that's all been from
incorporating my belief message and
really owning it and really having
confidence in it and really making that
the front line for everything that I do
those three things really helped me a
lot 1 mile and success realize I don't
think up with every new idea myself to
you can't do it alone bring on a team
even at the start of its people to help
you because they volunteer because their
friends and they'll like you I realize
you can't do this alone you need to have
a team
help you and 3 incorporate your one word
for you it was believed and not just
like little bits here and there but go
all in on it and it really helps you
start to attract the right kind of
customers audience traction you need for
your business those are my thoughts
there's a couple of comments coming into
them doing a live stream so knife 23
vibe what what about your momentum I
appreciate your job not quite sure what
you're asking there but in terms of
momentum uh one of the things that I
find really helps me is having a
schedule having an environment that
supports me I find I find for me I could
have the greatest day you know maybe
I'll and a big deal or maybe somebody
writes in and says that I've changed
your life or maybe you know you're just
having a great day and then I wake up
the next day and it's like poof it's
gone and like I don't know where that
energy and momentum went but I feel like
for me I have to start over every single
day and so when I realized that that was
happening to me I said instead of being
reactionary instead of waiting for
something great to happen in not
carrying me forward right maybe I watch
a video at four o'clock in the afternoon
and that drives me forward for the rest
of the day and then the next day it's
gone playing for it take that into
account and now I create a morning
routine that supports me that builds me
up that makes me want to think bigger
part of why I created the ants presso
series on my youtube channel was I
wanted something that motivated and
inspired me to think bigger to be around
these famous successful entrepreneurs
and try to absorb their knowledge and
wisdom and seeing the great things that
they're doing any advice that they're
sharing makes me want to go and do more
makes me want to be the best version of
myself helps me create the momentum in
my business and so understand your
cadence understand your rhythm and try
to figure out what gets you excited and
what gives you that momentum and then
plan it like don't wait for it to happen
don't don't be reactionary actively pond
into your schedule and for me first
thing in the morning so that I'm setting
myself
for an amazing day and then Kenneth
Thank You Adam for your channel
everything you share I appreciate the
love Canada thank you for watching a
live stream um so that's it happy monday
guys I hope that helped with the
question and if you guys are interested
in checking out the mastermind group
I'll leave a link in the description
below happy Monday I'll see you soon
belief